oui
depuis quelques années je suis
passionnée avec mes camarades afric
search par les questions d'emploi de
talent et on s'évertue depuis donc
presque vingt ans à identifier les
talents africains et voir dans quelle
mesure on peut leur offrir du job alors
talent nous sommes au coeur de des
talons ce choix puisque tous ceux qui
sont passés ont un vrai talent
excepté notre traducteur
bon je refais un dernier test et qui na
waïe akkaoui kananaskis
il est bon
il est très très bon là ça y est c'est
acheter nous sommes ensemble vos amis il
a raison alors je le disais les
questions d'emploi et de talent ça fait
bientôt une vingtaine d'années que nous
sommes dans ces problématiques
avec ce petit cerveau qui se baladent
quand après lebron james
effectivement en 1983 j'ai quitté lomé
chine et au togo
j'avais 13 14 ans et il paraît que je
suis ce petit cerveau qui se promène
avec les vanille et curieusement je
rends compte qu'il ya beaucoup de
cerveaux comme ça qui se promène avec
les valises qui partent d'afrique en
appel de bruyn rennes à tel point qu'on
dit qu'une personne sur neuf diplômés du
supérieur qui vit dans les piles de cd
eux via l'afrique c'est extraordinaire
extraordinaire et c'est des gens qui
réussissent et puis finalement je veux
dit mais comment se fait-il que en
afrique quand on regarde un peu les
chiffres et le chômage massif des jeunes
on s'aperçoit qu'à peu près plus de 80%
des jeunes sortent du système scolaire
sans qualification alors que c'est les
mêmes qui partent à l'étranger et qui
réussissent c'est surprenant qu'en
maintenant et avec le temps donc on se
posait la question de savoir comment se
fait-il que l'emploi et dans un sens et
puis ceux qui sont diplômés de l'autre
c'est à ceux qui ont étudié ne trouve
pas un job et des emplois disponibles
sur le marché ne trouve pas des preneurs
donc une forte il adéquation et puis
finalement à cette question c'est 10 mai
et un truc qui tombent pas en faut
peut-être réinventer la question de
l'emploi
parce que finalement l'afrique est quand
même pleine de talent et vous ne me
contredirez pas
parce que grâce aux technologies on fait
plein de choses
alors je vais me déplacer légèrement de
ce côté pour vous montrer l'image sur
mon téléphone
si ça fonctionne monsieur l'interprète
suivez mon regard et traduisez est-ce
qu'on va arriver à capter l'image sur ce
téléphone
qu'est ce que vous voyez
c'est un super camion africains qui
transporte l'équivalent de quatre
camions sur un seul camion
c'est extraordinaire ne bougeait pas une
deuxième arrive
qu'on veut ce qu'on fait lorsque le le
ramadan arrive
qu'il faut livrer la chèvre rapidement à
sa femme avant qu'elle ne quitte la
maison on le transporte sur un vélo on
va là une dernière image
comment est ce qu'on fait lorsqu'on n'a
pas de voiture mais fluctuant quand même
aller vite on la tâche à un âne et on
déplace la voiture merci beaucoup
monsieur donc je me dis mais si
finalement il ya autant de talents
exprimé différemment à travers ces
images comme ed voir comment se fait-il
que les jeunes que j'ai montré sur le
schéma 80% sortent sans qualification
et puis en même temps il ya de l'emploi
disponible
la question de fond c'est la question de
notre formation et c'est un sujet très
sérieux parce que tous les speakers qui
sont passés l'on abordé de manière
indirecte
comment peut-on faire un continent si
nous continuons d'accepter que plus de
80 % des jeunes sont au chômage et
soissons qualification nous devons
impérativement réinventer l'éducation
pour que tous ces jeunes qui sont
bourrés de talent ne finisse pas comme
des bombes humaines parce que c'est
vraiment ce que nous préparons et c'est
un sujet très sérieux par la formation
professionnelle la qualification tous
les systèmes d'enseignement modernes
aujourd'hui on peut changer réellement
l'afrique et l'afrique peut changer le
monde
la moitié des jeunes
ça met des africains dans quelques
années donc ça veut dire que le sommes
assis sur un réservoir incroyable
potentiel qui pendant ce temps peut
réinventer l'afrique parce que
finalement c'est cette jeunesse
africaine que nous devons réinventer ses
enfants qu'on voit là son plein de
talent et on le voit au quotidien en
fait on le voit au quotidien dans ce
qu'ils font et j'adore l'image de ce
bébé qui déjà tout petit
s'évertue à l'informatique et va
certainement écrire le prochain livre de
notre ami qui sera diffusé sur écran
géant à yopougon parce que là nous
serons dans la technologie aidant
l'afrique d'aujourd'hui parce que ce
sont ses enfants qui vont faire le monde
de demain
et ces images illustrent parfaitement
cette créativité cette inventivité qui
réside sur ce continent et se susurre
que plus de 90% des personnes assises
dans cette salle on déjà vu des enfants
qui ont fabriqué des téléphones à partir
de rien qui ont fabriqué de pièces
électroniques à partir de pièces
ramassées dans les poubelles et qui
fonctionne qui font des caméras etc etc
mon point c'est qu'en partant dans cette
initiative d'afrique search consacrée à
l'emploi en afrique et aux jeunes
on revient en arrière parce qu'on n'y
changent le monde s'est changé en fait
tout le processus
la conclusion c'est que le processus
devient destructeur
s'ils n'arrivent pas à capitaliser sur
ce génie créatif que tous ces gamins on
compte ils sont petits et convoque au
quotidien dans les rues africaine dans
les capitales africaines
comment on fait pour réinventer cette
créativité et de donner cette capacité à
ses enfants à tous ces africains pour
que ce soit eux qui portent le
changement parce que le changement est
nécessaire
le changement date est plus rapide et le
changement doit diriger désormais tout
ce que nous faisons en tant qu'africain
le mobile money qui a son équivalent au
kenya le système peu ça qui marche
formidablement qui permet de bancariser
presque le client ont-ils un free ne
reste pour des populations qui n'était
pas bon car ise ça a été une solution
qui a permis de changer complètement la
dynamique de milliers millions
d'africains en afrique de l'est
et ça se passe donc comment est ce que
chacun de nous dans notre approche
de ce que nous faisons au quotidien pour
l'afrique pour les jeunes pour nos
jeunes faria douceur on s'assure qu'ils
gardent en eux cette dose de créativité
mais sur laquelle il faut qu'on arrive à
capitaliser et ça ce n'est pas mon style
j'ai perdu mais ce live mais c'est pas
bien grave les images qui devait suivre
devait nous permettre de dire la
réinvention justement de ce mode de
créativité en afrique et de
capitalisation ne touche que ses enfants
s'affairent il faut qu'on arrive à le
traduire en projet et en accompagnement
de ces jeunes pour réinventer l'afrique
parce que finalement qui va s'approprier
l'afrique c'est qu'une bonne partie
d'entre nous ici est en même temps c'est
une bonne partie d'entre nous et mon
message à travers l' aventure d'afrique
search ou aujourd'hui plus de 500 cars
trouve un job grâce à nous parce qu'ils
arrivent à développer un talent on se
dit on a des milliers derrière qui ont
ce talent sur lequel on n'arrive pas à
capitaliser
l'afrique est en train de changer c'est
une réalité c'est perceptible dans les
villes à l'intérieur des pays ça l'est
un peu moins
cette société de consommation qui se met
en place avec cette inventivité qu'on
voit dans ces différents secteurs
si les vaches veut bien revenir à
l'écran parce que ça aussi ça fait
partie de l'afrique qui change
regardez tous ces secteurs on le voit
bien avant nous n'avions pas de champion
dans ces différents secteurs mais
aujourd'hui c'est une réalité dans les
produits de grande consommation dans
l'énergie dans les télécoms dans les
médias dans les sciences en afrique de
l'est en afrique australe au nigeria
bref l'afrique se construit en dépit du
peu de cas que nous faisons de ces
jeunes créatifs que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure et qui doit faire
l'histoire de l'afrique parce que
l'afrique change
on le voit à travers ces panneaux prix
en flash dans les villes africaines
la société de consommation s'est
installé les concepts sont familiers aux
afriques et aujourd'hui vous ne racontez
plus d'histoire en afrique est
aujourd'hui parce qu'il vit le monde
en afrique parce que l'afrique devient
le monde et tout mon obsession et toute
notre obsession c'est de se dire comment
est ce qu'on s'organise pour que ces
millions de jeunes africains qui voit ça
tous les jours deviennent les acteurs de
cette société que nous voulons changer
il est hors de question qu'ils ne soient
que des consommateurs passifs de tout
ceci
mais qu'ils soient les acteurs de ce
monde nouveau qui se créent sous nos
yeux et qui va une telle vitesse que
nous mêmes nous en perdons presque notre
latin s'ils ont pu dire
et j'aime bien cette pub de nos amis de
coca cola sans faire de pub pour eux les
avants 1 milliards de raisons de croire
en l'afrique parce qu'avec un milliard
d'individus
c'est un milliard d'individus qui
peuvent porter cette croyance et qui
peuvent changer l'afrique et sur ce
milliard
c'est qui la jeunesse représente une
formidable partie et donc je voudrais
qu'à travers ce ted x abidjan nous
construisions avec la jeunesse africaine
une nouvelle histoire du continent en
misant sur leur talent parce qu'on a vu
sur ce téléphone
ils n'ont pas attendu pour inventer tout
ce qu'on a vu merci beaucoup